hey guys it is Monday my name is Justin
you're watching games but news first up
it looks as if the legend of zelda
breath of the wilds development has
finished monolith soft developer yo
Sookie hun posted this image on Twitter
from the breath of the wild Ratt party
which took place at a hotel near
Nintendo's headquarters in Kyoto on
februari 3 according to Eurogamer as
explained by game informer monolith soft
helped out with development so it makes
sense they'd be at the wrap party if we
take a closer look you can see Shigeru
Miyamoto flanked by a man in a link hat
there's also this man in the front too
appears to be enjoying himself a legend
of zelda breath of the wild will launch
with the nintendo switch on march three
and will also be available on WE years a
bunch of new things are coming for
Rainbow six siege and here's everything
you'll want to know about that the
velvet shall update will include the
free map of coastline along with the two
new operators jackal and Mira who are
available as part of the games season
pass menus are being revamped so that
everything can be accessed from a single
page and there are new cosmetic items
such as weapon skins uniforms and
headgear weapon sights have also been
tweaked so that they appear identical
across seizures Arsenal later this year
matchmaking will get a complete rework
and a new loot system will be introduced
velvet shell arrives on februari 7
Ubisoft has also confirmed that rainbow
6 siege will not get any new game modes
instead focusing on adding maps and
operators finally over which director
Jeff Kaplan has spoken out about the use
of keyboard and mouse controls for the
popular shooter on consoles in a forum
post Kaplan said the overwatch team
objects to the use of mouse and keyboard
on console Kaplan said Blizzard what
Sony and Microsoft to either prohibit
the use of mouse and keyboard controls
and conversion devices or officially add
support for those control setups for
everyone Kaplan also encouraged gamers
to reach out to hardware manufacturers
and express their concerns in a
productive and respectful way as you've
imagined users who find ways to use
mouse and keyboard on their console are
afforded a lot
more precision and as a result have an
unfair advantage this is the same reason
that overwatch does not feature cross
play between PC and consoles that is
everything I have for you today to be
sure to head to gamespot for stories on
Conan exiles and horizon zero dawn and I
will catch you again tomorrow